Magnus going into today's rounds it felt
nearly similar to what happened in
Poland you were trailing by quite a few
points what was the goal uh on how many
points were you uh thinking of finishing
today's rounds the rapid rounds
um no I I mean I thought the first game
would be difficult and then the next two
I would have a good chance to win so
overall of course plus two is pretty
good and that's exactly what happened
and especially this final game it was a
bit shaky it felt at some point like
that exchange sacrificed by him
definitely it felt uncomfortable for you
yeah I mean
uh I don't know what I was thinking in
the opening I was thinking E5
um like there are similar lines for
instance with Bishop E2 uh immediately
um like
here E5 is a move I mean it's not a
great move but
um I I was I was thinking that
um I was thinking that you know with the
E3 at least no Bishop G5 is coming in
one go so I thought like for a moment I
was being clever but I just missed uh I
just missed C5 so this whole thing was
yeah this was this was terrible and here
after C6 I
also when I I I realize here I realized
quickly that group D6 is really strong
otherwise it's maybe kind of kind of
playable I mean
search positions
um I've seen I've seen them before and
with the bishop pair and
and
um
yeah well exactly the bishop there you
do have some long-term potentials
um and I think there was this yeah
I mean I I played I played knights in
Bishop E6 which was insane uh I was
focused on not going to C4 so first I I
didn't really understand what he was
doing since I thought like I'm I'm doing
fine now uh and then immediately as I
went Bishop D E6 I saw that he could
bring the Knight to B3 and then I
thought yeah now I'm probably probably
lost again
um
but yeah I mean whatever a lot of things
happened later but it was this also this
moment I'm not sure if you if you guys
caught it at one point after the move um
I think it was Rook to D1 Knight C5 Rook
C1 he had this move King to B2 oh my God
oh that's so disgusting yeah that's
really disgusting of course uh uh of
course I wanted to to sack The Exchange
and just win easily but
um
it's some sort of a study like yeah I
mean that's oh yeah that was
super careless
I think like in general I was just yeah
not in the right instead of mine for for
the last game like I was really really
happy with the win against student I
thought I calculated that very well uh
but then yeah in the last game
last game not focused enough but still
everything is uh well that finished uh
well and tomorrow perhaps one point
behind the leaders going into 18 rounds
of Blitz
certainly yeah
Nepal Drew as well yeah yeah
awesome obviously considering the
service that's
answerable uh
and um
I think a lot can happen
a lot can happen now in
him
um
uh I think Colorado is certainly the one
who has the highest potential of anyone
but
it's it's hard to say both Theon and
Fabi will probably
need to do something they've never done
before in order especially if like if
either
well especially if I have a if I have a
good blister
they will need to do something they've
really never done before in order to to
win but
um but that's not impossible of course
um otherwise yeah I'm happy to be you
know
you know um
so
so bad but today I felt a lot better
way that I
did that well today that would be
well definitely you have some inspiring
Blitz performances to get that
inspiration for tomorrow go get some
rest we'll see you tomorrow yeah thank
you guys back